Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
From many fond childhood memories, most of
us are quite fond of the colorful physical
appearance of bubbles and fuel-water mixtures.
We also know surprisingly little about this
peculiar phenomenon where the color of an
object changes when we either turn our head
or change the lighting.
This happens in a very colorful manner, and
physicists like to call this iridescence or
goniochromism.
What is even less known, is that if we try
to use a light simulation program to make
an image with leather, we'll be surprised
to see that it also shows a pronounced goniochromatic
effect.
An even more less known fact is that quite
a few birds, insects, minerals, sea shells,
and even some fruits are iridescent as well.
I've added links to some really cool additional
readings to the video description for your
enjoyment.
This effect is caused by materials that scatter
different colors of light in different directions.
A white incoming light is therefore scattered
not in one direction, but in a number of different
directions, sorted by their colors.
This is why we get these beautiful, rainbow-colored
patterns that we all love so much.
Now that we know what iridescence is, the
next step is obviously to infuse our light
simulation programs to have this awesome feature.
This paper is about simulating this effect
with microfacets, which are tiny microstructures
on the surface of rough objects.
And with this, it is now suddenly possible
to put a thin iridescent film onto a virtual
object and create a photorealistic image out
of it.
If you are into math and would like to read
about some tasty spectral integration in the
frequency space with Fourier transforms, this
paper is for you.
If you are not a mathematician, also make
sure to have a look because the production
quality of this paper is through the roof.
The methodology, derivations, comparisons
are all really crisp.
Loving it.
If you have a look, you will get a glimpse
of what it takes to create a work of this
quality.
This is one of the best papers in photorealistic
rendering I've seen in a while.
In the meantime, I am getting more and more
messages from you Fellow Scholars who tell
their stories on how they chose to turn their
lives around and started studying science
because of this series.
Wow.
That's incredibly humbling, and I really don't
know how to express my joy for this.
I always say that it's so great to be a part
of the future, and I am delighted to see that
some of you want to be a part of the future
and not only as an observer, but as a research
scientist.
This sort of impact is stronger than the absolute
best case scenario I have ever dreamed of
for the series.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!